shipments of chinese vaccines arriving
in egypt
manufacturers have struck deals to
supply 400 million doses to countries
around the world
despite having not yet released final
stage test results
more than one million people in china
have received doses under the
government's emergency program
beijing insists they're effective there
have been some adverse reactions
but none are serious more than 60 000
people have traveled to high risk areas
outside the country and so far there's
no serious infection
this proves our vaccines are protective
in a race to secure covert 19 jabs
nations like indonesia
turkey and morocco have signed
agreements with manufacturers
synovac synerfamp and canxino biologics
but some have questioned the safety of
chinese vaccines including brazilian
president jair bolsonaro
despite sao paulo state governor joao
doria already ordering millions of
synovic doses
cambodian leader jun sen says he won't
allow vaccines not recognized by the
world health organization
to be tested there previous vaccine
scandals in china
have led to concerns that manufacturers
may be cutting corners
in the past there were businesses that
broke the rules
for example vaccines won't store in
fridges
due to lack of transparency their
international reputation
has been undermined stricter regulations
in the us
uk and europe have required western
vaccine companies
to release trial data in stages chinese
companies have not been subject to the
same standards
china's leaders are depending on the
success of its vaccines to improve its
international image
which has suffered since the beginning
of the outbreak beijing has dismissed
concerns about quality
saying it's simply doing its part to
ensure developing nations have access to
a covert 19 vaccine
but experts say it has other motives
whoever has the most successful vaccine
the most efficacy vaccine will be able
to use that partly as a springboard
into other areas of medical diplomacy
but then beyond that
into perhaps trade or social cultural
connections
and eventually from there into
geopolitical concerns
beijing says it will be able to
manufacture 2 billion vaccines
by the end of next year katrina you al
jazeera beijing